...
Si j'ai bien compris ta question, c'est une question assez pertinente en fait, c'est une très bonne question.
Quelle est la différence entre la connaissance humaine que l'homme a et la connaissance humaine que Dieu a ?
Donc la connaissance humaine que Dieu a, c'est une connaissance, qu'on pourrait dire, basée sur son omniscience.
Il connaissait en avance, il y a d'autres dimensions là très importantes.
La première dimension c'est le fait que Dieu, tant qu'est créateur, tant qu'est roi, tant qu'est la source de tous les jugements moraux,
donc c'est à lui tant qu'est créateur, tant qu'est gouverneur, tant qu'est roi, et tant qu'est la source de tous les jugements moraux,
de dire qu'est-ce qui c'est bon, qu'est-ce qui c'est mauvais.
Donc il faut qu'il sache bien, faire la connaissance, et c'est même lui qui décide ce qui est bon, ce qui est mauvais.
Et à nouveau, toujours, on est protégé un peu par la nature même des dieux.
Et de l'autre côté, il y a cette différence entre la connaissance sans l'implication,
et la connaissance avec l'expérience.
Donc par exemple, on peut penser à un médecin, lui, il peut traiter quelqu'un qui a un cancer.
Il connaît bien, il est spécialiste dans les cancers.
Mais lui, il n'a pas les cancers.
Donc c'est ça un peu la différence.
L'homme, tant qu'est créature, il connaissait qu'il est bien, dans un sens.
Il ne connaissait pas les biens et les mauvais.
Mais une fois qu'il a pris la décision de désobéir à Dieu, de casser les pactes des oeuvres,
là il rentre dans la connaissance d'une dimension de la réalité qu'il ne connaissait pas avant.
C'est le mal.
Mais pourquoi Dieu dit, enfin Dieu,
empêchant-le maintenant d'avancer sa main, de prendre de l'art de vie, d'en manger et de vivre éternellement.
Pourquoi ?
Donc là c'est aussi très important, c'est une question majeure aussi qu'il faut toucher.
Ça c'est une démonstration déjà de la grâce souveraine des dieux.
Et ça bien sûr, quand on considère les faits qu'il avait laissé par exemple en Ephésien avant la fondation du monde,
il pensait déjà au salut.
Mais ça c'est dans les temps et dans l'espace, un type de protection des dieux.
Ça montre deux choses en fait.
qu'il a été créé par Dieu originellement, il était moralement parfait et parfait dans l'état où il se trouvait.
Mais il y avait encore un espace qu'on pourrait dire d'évolution.
Donc il pourrait devenir éternel si il passait par la preuve, par les pactes que Dieu avait accordés avec eux.
Donc ça serait un peu, c'est une notion d'éthlégien, c'est clair qu'on n'a pas une réponse finale,
mais je crois que c'est le maximum qu'on peut arriver, c'est cette notion-là.
Notamment quand on compare la condition de l'homme avec la condition des anges.
Donc Abil va dire que les anges sont très intéressés par rapport à cette notion de salut.
Il y a des dimensions des dieux qu'on ne connaissait pas sans la chute, la grâce, la miséricorde.
Dieu est saint et ceux qui pratiquent les péchés doivent être pournis.
Et donc pour que la condition de l'homme ne devienne pas éternelle,
la condition corrompue de l'homme ne devienne pas éternelle,
par sa grâce souveraine, Dieu empêche l'homme de prendre de la vie éternelle.
Il venait de péché et Dieu ne voulait pas qu'il reste éternellement comme ça.
Et une chose très intéressante aussi, ça touche un peu cette notion-là,
c'est qu'à partir du moment où Dieu, et ça c'est assez important quand on regarde Genèse,
Dieu est en train d'annoncer déjà ses promesses,
mais pas encore dans un langage complet, dans un langage de plénitude.
Parce que notamment, à partir du moment où le péché est rentré,
l'être humain a été corrompu même par rapport à sa connaissance de Dieu.
On a vu les réactions des hommes, etc.
Mais par exemple, il y a les proto-évangiles, quand Dieu dit,
de la descendance de la femme viendra un qui écrasera la tête du serpent,
ok, là c'est déjà un lance de Christ,
et Paul, il va vraiment, ça la réunion de ce qu'Marie a partagé,
il va se baser sur la particule de sangulier en fait,
pour dire, il ne dit pas des descendants, ça dit d'où descendants.
Et c'est là où il va montrer les Christ et les nouveaux adants.
Ça a beaucoup d'implications par rapport à la façon dont on prend Genèse aussi.
Et là, on voit aussi, quand ils sont chassés des désors,
Dieu, il va mettre, ça c'est étonnant,
il va mettre l'épée pour empêcher qu'ils reviennent au paradis,
mais qui est en train d'apporter l'épée ?
Ce sont les chéroubans.
Et à nouveau, en fait, les chéroubans,
ils représentent, quand on va aller passer à l'emploi chéroubans,
l'humanité glorifiée, restaurée en fait.
Il y a plusieurs types d'anges différents.
Et les chéroubans, ils apportent des têtes
qui représentent l'humanité restaurée, glorifiée,
et la nature même.
Et donc c'était comme c'était une promesse,
un jour, vous allez revenir,
mais pas maintenant.
Il y a l'épée, la flamboyante, ce qu'ils disaient.
Et donc c'est cet équilibre-là, toujours entre
la juste punition des dieux contre les pécheurs,
et la promesse annoncée de paradis qui s'est récupérée.
C'est une autre question.
Le serpent a été puni.
Le serpent animal a été puni.
Pourtant, il n'avait pas une responsabilité de discernir.
Donc pourquoi il a été puni ?
Autrement dit, est-ce que c'est juste une image symbolique
de l'ennemi, de l'adversaire, de Satan, de Lucifer,
ou est-ce que ça prend de l'éternité ?
Tous les êtres créés, ils étaient un peu...
Donc quelle était l'utilité de l'homme ?
Comment l'homme allait porter l'image de Dieu ?
Il y a plein d'implications.
Une de ces implications, c'est de la même façon
que Dieu gouverne toute la création,
crée toute la création.
L'être humain, l'homme et la femme,
ils ont reçu la tâche de représenter
les gouvernements de Dieu par rapport à toute la création.
Donc toute la création a souffert, dans un sens,
avec la condition de l'homme et de la femme.
Donc l'homme qui était la cuivre de la création,
sa tâche principale, c'était de prendre son objectif avant les dieux,
il a apporté la chute, pas seulement à lui-même,
mais à l'ensemble de la création.
Donc ça pourrait un peu justifier la punition aussi du serpent.
Mais en même temps,
et spécifiquement par rapport à ta question,
moi je n'ai pas une réponse,
et je crois que ça rentre un peu dans les mystères.
Donc ce ne sont pas des réglages exhaustives dans la Bible,
mais ce sont des réglages toujours suffisants,
surtout par rapport à la question du salut.
Et donc même en fait, cette représentation,
on se doute en fait si c'était Satan qui possédait les serpents,
ou juste son représentation par rapport aux astuces de Satan.
De toute façon, la grande question à poser toujours,
c'est quand on pense,
est-ce qu'on va traiter les textes de façon littérale ou pas,
c'est toujours d'abord,
on considère un autre moment actuel,
donc la tendance, la volonté de ne pas avoir ces choses comme littérale,
littérale, ouais ?
Ok, donc il faut faire attention à ça.
Et aussi, de l'autre côté,
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait,
on peut dire,
voir comme possible,
non littérale,
sans compromettre
des vérités profondes
que les écritures, elles, nous apportent.
Donc par rapport, par exemple,
les descendants,
il est lié directement à cette notion
d'écraser la tête du serpent.
Et comme l'apôtre Paul,
qui c'est une tête brillante,
là, beaucoup plus sage que plusieurs
de soi-là aujourd'hui,
donc si lui,
il s'accroche
à une notion tellement littérale
de ces textes-là,
c'est très difficile
de nous dire,
nous, on va vouloir supprimer
les surnaturels,
là-dedans.
Donc, pour moi,
c'est difficile
à ne pas prendre
ces textes-là
d'une façon littérale.
Mais,
si quelqu'un veut avoir
cette vision-là,
qu'au moins,
il puisse voir
les choses
qu'il ne peut pas
compromettre,
là-dedans.
Mais les serpents,
il a souffert,
c'est ça.
Ouais.
C'était,
je pense qu'il a
devenu un peu
impur
par rapport
à l'utilisation
que chacun a fait
d'Eloïde.
Il y a des conséquences.
Mais lui,
il n'avait été pour rien,
il n'a rien fait.
Il n'avait pas
la possibilité
de dire
oui.
Mais là,
en fait,
la pureté...
C'est pas le seul
à remonter
par terre non plus.
Les terres de terre,
les machins...
Je pense qu'il a...
Les coulères,
les manges...
Donc...
Ouais,
c'est ça.
Un mec,
lui,
il a eu
une punition spécifique.
Ouais.
Mais le plus intéressant,
le plus intéressant,
ce n'est pas des voiles...
Sa plus grande position,
c'était le fait
que sa tête,
ça allait être écrasée.
Ça,
c'est dériger vers Satan.
Et bien sûr,
ses autres implications
sont plutôt dériger vers Satan.
Ça veut dire,
la condition
où il se trouve maintenant,
qui était déjà déchute,
ça va être encore pire,
en fait.
Sa puissance,
son actuation
sera toujours limitée.
Et c'est progressivement
vers là qu'on voit
jusqu'à ce que sa tête
soit vraiment écrasée
par Jésus.
Mais le plus intéressant,
dans la vie,
ce sont les punitions
que nous,
on a reçues,
en fait.
L'homme et la femme.
car ça,
c'est très régulateur,
pas qu'en fait,
de notre coupabilité,
mais aussi
de notre nature originale.
Pour moi,
c'est quelque chose
d'étonnant.
Pourquoi on a reçu
exactement
les punitions
qu'on a reçues,
l'homme et la femme ?
Pour moi,
ça,
c'est une très bonne question
qui je vous pose.
Est-ce que le jardin
est toujours sur terre
ou on peut
la remporter ?
Oui,
c'est une très bonne question.
Moi,
je crois
que ça serait très difficile.
Si on met
dans Google Maps,
on fait un peu de recherche.
Non, c'est vrai,
on a un peu le droit
où ça serait
ça serait
les jardins.
Mais bien sûr,
après la chute,
il n'y a plus
la même chose.
Pour les punissons,
normalement,
elles sont annulées
que du coup,
quand on donne
cette vie à Dieu,
ces punissons-là
sont annulées.
Elles sont,
je ne dirais pas
qu'elles sont annulées,
mais qu'on vit encore.
C'est dur
pour le même chrétien.
La grossesse,
la grossesse,
l'accouchement,
le travail.
Je ne suis pas souhaitée.
Mais moi,
pour la fin,
par exemple,
l'accouchement,
j'aime bien
parce que c'est repris
à chaque fois
quand on pense
à la venue
du royaume de Dieu,
la venue
de Christ,
nous-mêmes
qui vivons
sur cette terre,
toute la création
qui s'ouvre
pour des couleurs
de l'enfant du monde.
À chaque fois,
l'enfant du monde,
c'est toute notre souffrance
ici,
avant que la joie
arrivera
quand on sera avec Christ,
quand on sera délivré,
que le royaume de Dieu
nous vient,
c'est ce parallèle-là.
C'est ça.
Même la création,
aujourd'hui,
elle a l'anxiété
de voir la pleine manifestation
des enfants de Dieu.
C'est-à-dire,
la deuxième venue
de Christ
et la nature
qui sera rachetée
aussi avec nous,
les êtres.
pour moi.
Je vais dire juste quelques mots
par rapport à ça.
Si on revient
à la condition
de l'homme
et de la femme,
l'homme
et la femme
ont été créés
à l'image de Dieu
dans une relation
de complémentarité
pour réfléchir
à la complémentarité
de la Trinité.
Dieu Père,
Dieu Fils,
Dieu Saint-Esprit
et l'homme
dans la même notion.
Et donc,
soit
dans les étapes
de péché,
donc l'homme
par omission
qui ne prend pas son rôle,
il était là
tout le temps,
il est un peu lâche
par rapport
aux choses
que la femme
est en train de faire
et la femme
qui prend le leadership
et donne
les fruits
à l'homme.
là,
on va déjà un peu,
ils sont en train
de casser
une loi claire
que Dieu les a donnée
et ils sont en train
de casser
les lois claires
qu'il les a donnée
en cassant aussi
leur nature complémentaire,
si on peut dire
comme ça.
Et c'est très intéressant
quand on regarde
l'histoire de l'humanité
et donc ça vient
la punition
et là,
quand on rentre
dans la punition,
on a la notion
de l'essence
de la femme
et l'essence
de l'homme
touchée
et aussi
l'utilité
de la femme
et de l'homme
touchée.
Donc,
c'est une question
de la nature,
donc notre nature
tant qu'homme
et femme,
c'est quelque chose
qui a été créé
pour vivre ensemble
dans une harmonie
et là,
en fait,
chapitre 3,
verset 16,
il dit à la femme
« Je m'enterrai
la souffrance
de tes grossesses »
et l'homme,
il a dit
l'ordre,
c'était
de multiplier
et de faire
fécond,
c'est ça,
donc,
c'est une demande
presque essentielle
en fait,
de libérer
une famille,
de gérer
donc l'homme
et la femme,
au travers
des choses
qui font partie
de son essence,
donc ces grossesses
seront entre deux heures,
et ça,
il y a des implications
aussi pour élever
les enfants,
c'est bien sûr,
mais tes désirs
se porteront vers ton mari,
donc cette notion
de désir,
c'est le désir
vraiment,
le désir
de gouverner,
donc tu vas vouloir
gouverner ton mari,
tu vas vouloir
prendre la direction,
mais,
comme réponse,
ton mari,
au lieu de te servir
dans les schémas
de leadership,
il va te gouverner,
il va sous-juger,
ce n'est plus en fait
la notion
de partager
une même mission
avec des structures
différentes
et complémentaires,
c'est une division
dans l'essence
de l'être humain,
soit la femme,
soit l'homme,
c'est cette
inimitié
qui touche.
Et quand on regarde
l'histoire,
on va voir vraiment ça,
pendant dégénération,
l'homme qui est en train
de,
comment on peut dire,
sous-juger les femmes,
et après,
là,
il y a une grande réaction,
avec tous les effets
collatérales,
il y a de très bonnes choses,
ils sont en train
dégénération,
toutes les choses,
mais les mouvres en pénis,
qui ont des effets
très bons,
mais qui,
à la fin,
apportaient beaucoup
d'effets collatéraux,
si on peut dire comme ça.
Par rapport à la chute,
à la punition aussi,
on voit aussi
une chute
dans les bénédictions
que Dieu accordait
à chacun.
L'homme était placé
comme étant,
entre guillemets,
la perte de la création,
l'image de Dieu,
et en fait,
l'homme perd sa place
en devenant
travailleur dur,
qui perd son état
de statut
de privilégié,
et la femme
qui perd totalement,
pour le coup,
enfin,
qui perd pas totalement,
mais avec une difficulté,
la plus grande bénédiction
qu'elle peut avoir,
c'est-à-dire,
se multiplier,
porter,
porter la vie,
c'est pourquoi
la femme a aussi été créée,
donc elle perd aussi
cette bénédiction de Dieu
en devenant plus compliquée
avec des complications.
Mais oui,
les désirs
qu'on a envie
de l'être lui,
enfin,
de l'épreuve,
de l'épreuve.
En français,
c'est ce que ça veut dire,
c'est qu'on a envie
de l'attention de quelqu'un.
Quand on arrive
au Nouveau Testament,
ça fait partie
vraiment
des structures de l'homme.
L'homme,
il voit la femme,
il fait un problème,
avant la chute.
Et quand on arrive
au Nouveau Testament,
Paul,
il va résoudre,
en fait,
l'homme,
il doit lidérer
sa famille,
son épouse,
comme Christ,
il va lidérer l'Église,
il a les mêmes amours,
et l'épouse,
elle doit honorer,
donc elle doit
fortifier,
auxilier,
affirmer
cette leadership.
Et Paul,
à la fin,
il va conclure
en disant
la femme,
l'homme,
qu'il aime son épouse
et qu'il est son épouse,
respecte son âge.
Donc,
cette notion
de respect et amour,
ce sont des demandes
plus basiques
qu'on peut imaginer
par rapport à l'homme
et la femme,
donc des différences basiques
qu'on peut penser.
cette notion-là,
elle est correcte,
mais elle ne s'applique pas
dans ses textes
spécifiques.
D'accord ?
Donc,
on peut rentrer là
dans les textes.
Pour ceux
que ça intéresse,
il y a un scientifique
qui a émis
une théorie
qui s'appelle
le désir mimétique.
Oui.
En fait,
il a analysé
toutes les cultures
archaïques,
sauvages,
entre guillemets,
civilisées,
et tout ça.
Et il s'est rendu
compte d'une constante
à savoir que
ce qui est à la base
d'une culture humaine,
c'est le désir mimétique.
Le désir mimétique,
le mimétisme.
Et qui débouche après
sur ce qu'il a appelé
la théorie du bouc-ennissaire,
etc.
Il a démontré
que c'est en fait
le fondement
de toutes les cultures.
lui,
c'est un anthropologue.
Donc,
il a travaillé
avec des...
Comment on appelle ça
des...
Ethnologues.
Voilà.
Et donc,
lui,
il est chrétien
et il a démontré
scientifiquement
ce...
Voilà,
Enfin,
il a démontré...
Il a émis
cette théorie,
comment dire,
corrobée
par des faits
observés
dans toutes les sociétés,
qu'elles soient
mérindiennes,
que ça date
de X siècle,
ou même
dans la société
actuelle.
Cette concentration-là,
alors c'est intéressant
quand tu donnes
cette interprétation
du désir,
ça rejoint un petit peu
ce qu'il dit.
D'accord.
Et vous pouvez
faire vos recherches
sur Internet
si ça vous intéresse.
C'est René Girard,
en fait.
Il vient de décéder,
il a,
il y a quelques mois.
Et ouais,
c'est intéressant.
Super.
Bon,
je vais juste dire
un mot.
C'est clair
qu'aujourd'hui,
on a une notion
des complémentarités,
des soumissions
très compliquées
et importantes
car c'est bien marqué
par cette période
de domination
des hommes
envers la fin.
Donc,
avant de rentrer
dans ces textes bibliques-là,
il faut qu'on fasse
un nettoyage
des notions qu'on a
et de nous rappeler
qu'on a été créé
l'image des dieux.
Donc,
en dieu,
on trouve une harmonie
entre des personnes
différentes,
on peut dire comme ça,
distinctes,
mais qui sont en train
d'avoir un même but,
une unité,
des buts communs
et qui travaillent
dans une division
de travail,
on peut dire
avec une relation
d'autorité
et de soumission.
Donc,
les pères
qui envoient
les fils,
les fils qui vont
se soumettre
à la volonté de père,
mais volontairement,
avec la conviction
que ça,
c'est la bonne chose
à faire
et le Saint-Esprit
envoyé par les pères
et les fils
pour être
ces auxiliaires
de la Trinité.
Ça,
c'est assez intéressant.
Les noms
que la Bible utilise
pour les Saint-Esprits,
c'est le même noms
que la Bible utilise
pour la femme.
Ça veut dire
sans les soutiens,
sans les secours
de cet élément-là,
tu n'es pas complet.
C'est pour ça
que Dieu
crée d'abord l'homme
et les met dans les jardins
pour voir les besoins
qu'il a
d'être complétés
par un autre.
Et ça,
à la fin,
c'est juste
une image
que Dieu veut montrer
pour comment l'Église
doit fonctionner aussi.
Donc,
rien n'empêche
que des personnes
qui ne sont pas
encore mariées
puissent trouver
en fait,
une partie
de cette dimension
de complémentarité
au sein de la communauté.
Donc,
ça a plein d'implications,
mais c'est bien
décadré un peu
pour ne pas faire sembler
que la notion
qu'on apporte des solutions,
c'est la même notion
qu'on a ajouté.
Tu dis que la femme
a devenu une autre
que le Saint-Esprit ?
Oui,
quand la Bible dit
une aide
qui lui soit...
Le qualificatif,
le qualificatif,
c'est...
Je lui apporterai
une aide
qui soit à ses côtés,
non pas pour être...
Enfin,
pas autour de sa tête,
mais machin.
Oui,
une aide idéale,
c'est un peu ça
les langues publiques.
Ces langues-là,
aide,
c'est vraiment
les langues
qu'il utilise
pour le Saint-Esprit.
Quand il dit
aux apôtres
de l'Adam,
l'aide,
c'est ça ?
Ça ne tue pas ?
Quand il dit aux apôtres...
L'aide,
les consulateurs,
c'est ça.
Et les deux mots,
c'est...
Parapétos,
en grec,
parapétos,
ça peut être compris.
C'est compris dans la notion,
mais c'est pas...
C'est pas les mêmes mots
hébraïques, là.
D'accord.
Et je ne rappelle pas
les mots,
exactement.
Mais,
continuons,
donc...
Par contre,
j'ai juste une dernière question.
C'est quoi l'arbre
de la vie
et de la connaissance ?
Comment ?
De l'arbre
de la vie
et de la connaissance.
L'arbre de la vie,
de la vie éternelle
et de la connaissance
du bien et du mal.
Il y avait ces deux arbres
dans les yadrans
qui avaient un peu
un sens spécial.
Il y en avait deux
ou je ne sais pas
entre l'arbre ?
Il y en avait plus.
Il n'a jamais obligé
de manger l'arbre
de la vie éternelle.
C'est ça.
Mais dans la photo
on fait le rapprochement
avec les arbres
aussi qui reviennent
et Jésus dit
j'aborderai
tous pour
manger de...
Pour moi,
l'une des choses
les plus belles...
Parce que c'est
un métaphore
pour le groupe.
Je ne sais pas
si c'est un métaphore
ou si c'est réel.
Moi, je crois
que c'est un rapport
qui...
Pour moi,
ce n'est pas forcément
que l'arbre
ait un potentiel magique.
C'est juste
quelque chose
que Dieu a choisi
qui est à la légère.
C'est bien garanti.
Mais...
Mais qui Dieu
a résolu
de faire un accord
qui représentait
quelque chose
beaucoup plus grand.
Pour moi,
à mon avis,
des créatures
des dieux,
elles sont des créatures
qui Dieu pourrait
arbitrer librement.
Mais comme il a créé
son image,
il nous a donné un peu
au début
cette libre arbitre.
et donc,
c'était un peu
un épreuve
pour voir
si l'homme aussi,
il allait volontairement
se soumettre
à la volonté
de Dieu.
C'est cette participation
dans cet accord
qui, par grâce,
même cet accord-là,
c'est une grâce
de Dieu.
Car Dieu,
tant qu'est-ce souverain,
créateur,
il pourrait juste exiger
ce qu'il veut.
Mais ce n'est pas
quelque chose
d'un récréable.
Et c'est vraiment
dans cette conséquence-là,
les jours où on décide
nous éloigner
des dieux,
on va conclure
qu'il est le plus
préjudi.
C'est nous-mêmes,
en fait.
C'est un peu
cette notion-là.
Mais c'est un accord
qu'il doit faire
avec des implications
et des raisons
derrière beaucoup
plus profondes
qu'il est les symboles
qu'il a choisi
d'utiliser
ou les matériels
qu'il a choisi
d'expercer.
Et c'est très intéressant
quand on voit
la femme
et la suggestion
de serpent
prend et mange
ce sont les mêmes mots
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
quand on parle
par rapport
à la sainte scène.
Donc,
prend et mange.
entre les prends et mange
du Christ
et les prends et mange
de la pomme,
Dieu a dû
beaucoup souffrir.
C'est un phrase
assez forte
qui est un peu
éliminée.
!
Juste une petite question
David,
s'il te plaît.
Quand il est écrit
« L'homme est devenu
comme l'un d'entre nous »
c'est exprès
!
ou ça peut être traduit
« L'homme est devenu
comme nous »
parce que ce n'est pas
la même chose.
En fait,
oui,
l'homme,
dans plusieurs sens,
il était déjà
à l'image de Dieu
donc il partageait
plusieurs choses
en commun avec Dieu.
Mais c'était la question
qu'Eline a posée
d'abord.
C'était India
ou quelle est la première question?
India.
Oui, c'est India.
Donc,
cette connaissance
de bien et de mal,
c'est la chose-là
qui dit
que Dieu va dire
non, c'est par rapport
à ça que c'est
qu'on est dit.
Ils sont devenus
comme nous
car ils connaissent
maintenant les biens
et les mal.
Ma question,
ce n'est pas ça.
C'est pourquoi
il dit
« Comme l'un d'entre nous »
parce que j'imagine
que dans l'hébreu
c'est « Elohim »
et « Elohim »
au pluriel.
Mais pourquoi
il dit « comme l'un d'entre nous »
à supposer
que dans la Trinité
il y a les trois personnes.
Est-ce qu'il fait allusion
à l'une des trois personnes?
Sinon,
pourquoi il n'aurait pas
traduit
il n'aurait pas écrit
directement
mais il est devenu
comme nous.
Comme nous.
Oui, ça ne peut être
comme nous.
Je ne sais pas.
Il a dit
« un »
dans la traduction
c'est comme nous.
Ah, voilà.
C'est non, ça ne peut être
comme nous.
Ah, ok.
Donc il y a une subtilie
de traduction apparente
parce qu'ailleurs
c'est pas comme nous.
Comme nous.
Il va parler
à l'ébreu.
Il ne va pas être
C'est pas sûr.